[Music]
hey
what's up
what's going on
youtube is broken man ain't nobody need
well anyway
today we're playing some world of tanks
i played this game i think two times
before on this channel
every time i record one of these i am so
bad
to get any footage i have to record for
so long
because i'm just that bad
but it's okay let's try out soviet
no swedish smee dish
get away sweden there you go stupid
sweden
i want the t-45
hmm oh it looks like the guy is inside
the tank look at him so tiny
[Music]
nah i want one with high fire power
what is this 46 55
28 oh yeah oh i like this tank
let's go this
[Music]
this is a sponsored video thank you
world of tanks for sponsoring very epic
let's hope i don't embarrass them
like i'm embarrassing myself
epic war music let's put that up in the
background
maybe that'll
sentimental elegant
kill kill them
very good this is my russian accent okay
we'll not be it
are they shooting or rebounding we're
bombing the city cool
it happens it's war it's okay it's
illegal
isn't it kind of [ __ ] up you can just
like
kill people in war
and it's like totally cool that's crazy
man
more got me like what is happening okay
my strategy is the same as mr
h35 and l6 just flank them
okay everyone has the flank strat it
doesn't work if everyone flanks guys
[ __ ] sake mine
[Music]
i just need my first kill that's all i
want
is anyone in the livestream yet oh we
got two people what up guys
welcome to the youtube mystery of why
my streams aren't going out
i hope you guys doing good
okay straight edge g16 there we go
[Music]
this music doesn't fit at all i kind of
like it
i need this kill i need this first kill
to start up
everyone is flanking on the right dude
okay new strategy wait for everyone to
flank
and then whenever oh we got our first
target mr pz
2 once everyone is flanked
i come in for that after everyone is
flying flank
the most efficient are they here or
behind the mountain
now this should be they should be here
oh god
oh i missed don't shoot me don't shoot
me
see what i said about the flank
they failed the flank look how low hp
you're dead
flanker number two is doing a lot of
damage now i come
in to steal the kill now i come in just
let me steal the kill
damn it i was so close
use you fake flanker
fake flank oh god there's more and
they're getting shot at there we go
one name here oh did 32 damage let's go
oh critical damage my kill my kill
where you going son ah skedaddle
ah that's not gonna hit okay we gotta
watch out for our flank though
ah what'd i say they double flank us
what's my health what's my health what's
my health i can't keep track
stop shooting me
[ __ ] oh yeah tank tank the tanker
this is my kill move my him like here
stealers what's my health
oh i didn't take that much damage okay
flank the flank [ __ ] we're playing
world of tanks [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's free you guys can download and play
with me actually
oh still still coming never mind
we're literally in their base now i'm a
wee bit worried
okay here we come here comes the flank
the ultimate flank of all flanks
[ __ ] oh it flew to the sky
[ __ ]
where did they go they disappeared in
the bush
oh i don't like this how many of them
are left they have a lot of people tanks
like what the [ __ ]
this is a suicide mission here
oh mate if we can pull this off it'll be
the greatest flank of all time
let's not get tunnel vision here
we got a flank you see there he's
working
ah damn it come on come on
all right all right
wait i gotta kill
die die
yeah let's go no i didn't kill him
a successful flank that's
how it's done all right let's get this
base it's ours
while you were busy wanking we were
fine all right
[Music]
just give us their base oh are they
trying
cringe
no okay we got it no
eight more seconds
tank gang why is it taking so long
12 seconds oh
we're under flank no
three seconds here we go how many of
them are left four
okay we gotta get a kill in here
why am i not moving we draw because no
no
are you serious
this some [ __ ]
epic music i need epic music for this
at least we didn't lose a tank this is
epic music
[Music]
draw get out here again
this makes me want to kill some people
this music is it
black shirt again haha what what's so
funny about that
i'm opening up for everyone
welcome welcome non-members
[Music]
it's time to murder people that undocks
my account here or something
game is free come play with me hooray
this is music to kill people too it's
the same man
hell yeah
yeah we're playing with tanks baby
i didn't catch it because he kept
leaving the area yeah but we captured it
i didn't leave the area
i was flanking the area back and forth
[Music]
yeah i heard k signs new song it was
pretty good actually
i'm glad he's trying out different stuff
okay so now we
know how they flank us but they're not
gonna flank us
[Applause]
because we are flanking them we're the
flankery no time for fear
only kill
excuse the ugly thumbnail in this stream
as well
photoshop wouldn't launch for whatever
[ __ ] reason and i just had to
screenshot him
i like this game i'm just so bad at it
teach me anyone know i don't need your
help that was a test
[Music]
we're gonna flank them yet again
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the flank is failed
[ __ ] i go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
this man is crazy
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he's gonna die you're dead
you're dead mate
he doesn't know how gold doesn't know
i go we'll go go bye bye i go doesn't
know
[ __ ] come on [ __ ]
haha go home [ __ ] come on come on come
on come on come on
fight me fight me i missed
[Music]
oh he's almost dead he's running you
can't flee from the swede
is back up one more shot and he's dead
one more shot in his name bye bye
successful flank we've done it mission
completed
now we go home our friend died this is
so sad
too bad i have to go home i realize war
is not what i want
[Music]
sure i was going to anyway mate oh god
i'm driving into
[ __ ] oh my god move uh he's getting me
killed team kill report him report him
guys
oh he's right there [ __ ] okay i got a
hit on him
you're not gonna kill me oh [ __ ]
ricochet
[ __ ] [ __ ] you scared
oh [ __ ] they're shooting me from all
angles
took your drift go go go go
oh we made it out of lab we made it out
of lab
no we just started streaming
[Music]
i'm depressed at work save me come play
world of tanks
that sucks you gotta work on a sunday
dude
okay long shot there he comes
oh [ __ ] i just shot a church i didn't
mean to sorry
it's fine how do we get down from here
here we go
there we go
[Applause]
all right this time we're flanking them
by going straight at them
some would say that's not a flank but
they don't know flanking like i do
this music [ __ ] sucks
oh nope
sorry whoever's growing wine i'm sorry
i'm helping you
we're following pizza yag
no i'm a soviet tank actually i'm not
swedish i'll switch to swedish later
here we go look how many kills we can
steal here
oh this is beautiful
so much potential please no don't die
don't die don't die don't think
we're gonna slink through the cracks
here where is he
oh [ __ ] is behind it oh
can i oh
come on i can't see him
ah wasn't me it wasn't me
[Music]
where are they there's two left that's
got to be over here
oh
[Music]
what's a flank it's a type of food
swedish dish where are they all right
i guess we should take their basement
oh dang it
[Music]
sun suit simulator exactly
i got many new haters from darman fans
good
that that's impossible dharma's videos
are only positivity and not caring about
haters this makes
no sense you are your mind mike you
don't care about winning anymore
must kill come on
come on oh i see him oh
my kill my kia damn it i missed
who's gonna win out of those two
hey zero devs all right
i'm doing way better than i thought
flanking works kids
[Music]
remember
the [ __ ] is this music man praise and
worship oh
okay
music is not it
[Music]
let's go survive baby
soviet will reign i like this tank let's
do it again
i wanted more music what is this [ __ ]
shape
epic
chasing okay
that no that's not what i wanted
okay how about this battle maybe battle
music will do it oh
oh yeah it builds
it builds oh this is it
this is flanking music
this is commit war crime music i like it
[Music]
dormant diss track oh i thought he did
it one on me for a second that would be
beautiful
[Music]
you're trying to get in the same battle
hey let me know if you do
and don't shoot me and i promise i won't
shoot you
that's how war works okay
it doesn't matter if we're on different
sides bros don't kill each other
[Music]
flank time it's coming
oh no one else is going this way this is
perfect
i'm on testing okay first of all we're
the first flank so we gotta
anticipate their flank we're gonna set
up
flank for their flank
in our flank over this flank
yes okay i'm getting pumped up
this will work 100
[Applause]
sorry whoever lives here i apologize
[Music]
you really shouldn't have put a wall
there to be honest
how the [ __ ] are my teammates already up
there god damn it
correction nine year old there's our
first flanker of the flank
[ __ ] oh he doesn't see me
oh you got scared now [ __ ] run
run you fool he doesn't know
who puts a bunch of bases here i'm sorry
base collector
he doesn't know he hasn't spotted us
the flanker gets flanked
idiot before we're gonna come up behind
him
he doesn't know poor child
so young he doesn't know
[ __ ] we might get spotted here actually
[ __ ]
oh this is a good flank what am i doing
critical damage there's nothing why am i
i can't i can't shoot that far [ __ ] ah
we've been flanked oh god we're getting
double flame
oh they're so bad what are they doing
they don't know how am i how am i lying
okay let's get this guy out of the way
where the [ __ ] did he go there you are
stop it
stop you can't circulate the house stop
look how scared he is
stop it
damn it he hit us critical damage but no
damage
let's get his treadmills
run run [ __ ]
what is he doing
what is he doing come back no
no no no you can't flank the flanker
[ __ ] oh he's got the advantage now
[ __ ] oh my [ __ ] god they're
everywhere they're flanking me
help this music sucks
it's the music's full
[ __ ] gross i need backup
calling all nine year olds no don't peek
me
don't [ __ ] peek me i'm dead you snake
stop damn it
i asked for backup
god [ __ ] damn it i'm so mad
now the epic music comes
all right it's fine we're just warming
up
it's all right mate it's fine don't even
care
don't even [ __ ] get
with switching over to japan has japan
any good tanks
let's check it out
no no
no japan worthless
let's do it okay let's try it japanese
tank let's go
yeah join uh join that same time steve
come in
stick with your teammates yeah but they
like me bro thank you brody for the
donation by the way
very kind of you
okay yeah you're i'm no no i changed my
mind japanese tank no good sorry
japanese
um maybe british
so so weak oh
okay maybe the milk a milk cruiser
spot in
yeah yeah i like this
this little dude
weave tank
have you guys seen the japanese army
recruitment is using like anime
drawings and [ __ ] i don't know if it's
real or not but i saw an advertisement
for
the japanese army and they they were
like hey
sure someone invited me i can't click
yes i'll join you later
um yeah it was all japanese style
i want to see an uh i want to see a tank
wrapped in anime here check this out
hold up
this is japanese uh army helicopter
let's go
gotta gotta if you die from that you
can't even be mad
i be like that's pretty epic actually
i just got blasted pieces by an anime
helicopter that's pretty cool
that's what i want my tank to be but
i just got bombed by [ __ ] weep
stealth thousand
oh swedish tank let's stick with the
swedish tank boy
the brits and the sweets eh
that's sick oh yeah
what the [ __ ] no way that's real
japanese military is getting offensively
cute
that's the headline i haven't looked
more into it
hey come back you [ __ ] swede you're
going with me
yeah we're playing world of tanks if you
guys want to join me it's free to
download and if you use the link in
description you get a bunch of free
bonuses so
do it use it click it
can you help me push me up push me up
i'm too slow push me up
please please give me a push-up push me
up push me up please
wait why is he dodging me help help i
need help
mate mate just give me a push please
tank together strong remember oh he's
got the dia he's got it thanks
what a bro thanks together strong
thanks man
oh my god this uphill dude it better be
worth it mate
give me boo oh he's waiting for me how
cute
we're best friends oh he's
okay give me a push and let's go
no this is war baby let's go
i'm [ __ ] ready oh gosh are they
everywhere
we should be okay here he's using me as
shield
he's cheating oh [ __ ] we could have
killed him
how are we caught up with the sweden oh
we're so fast now
yeah peak [ __ ] peek
oh we got a good shot in
finish him oh one more
run you fool i almost shot my teammates
don't steal a kill all right fine you
know what i'll allow it
see if we can snipe from here brody
again cheers mate
appreciate yet
okay we gotta be able to snipe from here
right oh
oh it shoots double ain't really you
must be [ __ ] confused what's
happening
that's a far shot i don't know if i can
make that
ah dang it you lucky
you're lucky you're alive
there's got to be other people i can
shoot oh
oh no i can't look that far down
okay [ __ ]
it's impossible armor not okay we hit
him
[Applause]
stop moving stop moving stop
stop stop
oh oh oh oh that was clean oh
come on come on come on come on come on
come on my kill my kill reload reload
reload reload reload reload reload
they're just circling he's got one
health
damn it i'm so close
there's only one left
that's cool i didn't realize you could
go up here
hey another win
teamwork tank together strong
there i'm playing amazingly this is
incredible
me see if i can find more of what i was
talking about
japanese military taps anime for
recruitment campaign
i can't be real
holy [ __ ] look at this
we've been doing war wrong all this time
where is it
okay let me just join a new game really
quick this is the same one i like that
thing
look at this i want a tank i want a tank
anime tank
oh let's go
let's [ __ ] go this feels
this feels my inner spirit
this is what i want world of tanks
please hook me up
please
oh is it too much to ask
i don't think so
let me just get the music going battle
of wills
oh slime uses this all the time okay
we're gonna flank
i'm from the mountains
let's go channel that enemy energy
oh wait i'm a british tank [ __ ]
[Music]
no way that gets deployed
no you're probably right but still
a kd on that thing can you imagine
[Music]
okay i actually don't know if it's a
good idea to flank here i think waiting
for them to show up
and catching them off guard is probably
a bad idea
especially since we're in the [ __ ]
middle but what did i say
who shot me stop stop
i said stop oh this [ __ ] rooney
i'm so dead i'm so dead i'm gonna die
why am i not moving
save me save me
sake
nothing happened look at anime tank
[Music]
hey remember when i said we should wait
for them and they didn't exact
thank to me oh you couldn't see the game
well that's probably for the better
look at that look at that that's the
gameplay
i was too busy killing the entire team i
got an ace that was sick
that was awesome
[Music]
okay let's try the swedes
hey huh
[Music]
yes
i'll accept your invitation
okay they're waiting for me apparently
wait wait wait wait wait
uh i have to select the tier three no no
no let's do tier two
i ain't doing this make it to one
dodge okay sure
bonds we have major leaf jakobson
captain headman
captain lundin very nice
okay i just got to select the tier 2
vehicle
the l60
garbage there we go
[Music]
i selected them
there we go yes all right i'm playing
with you guys now
could i oh they're clients they got
clients and [ __ ]
all right well prepare to finally get
somewhere
with this client
so i'm about to carry your asses and you
know
[Music]
that paul polish
that france and the french and the
swedes are all coming together
[Music]
sweden tanks are garbage felix how dare
you
how dare you uninstall yourself please
oh apparently happy birthday joseph i
didn't see that but
have a great one happy father's day as
well
there we go okay where are my teammates
then there
and there oh they're right between me
okay they're saying they'll help me
thanks
yo hey
okay you guys take the lead and i'll
follow him
what the [ __ ] is this right
okay we're going this way damn i'm
[ __ ] fast dude
yeehaw [ __ ] bye
oh i pick like that weakest fast tank or
some [ __ ] what is this there's a ton of
people that
no that's not in the platoon that's in
the game
yeah i think these people are also
nine-year-olds
all right guys we're gonna do swedish
meatball foundation
formation foundation two on top of this
hill
they'll never see it coming
actually never mind we go here change my
mind
oh our first target well spotted
he's dying will assist
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i got shot
just shoot him there you go
bro you're blocking me there you go one
more he's dead
let's go let's go
another one meatball foundation
oh bro bro bro behind us [ __ ]
[ __ ] not butter plain oh you're so tiny
and pathetic you will not kill me you're
too
tiny small and bad
swedish street swag
let's go all right
roland tank together strong
as close as possible
oh oh
he's peeking hey you better run
oh he's afraid he has no
chance come on come on come on
still kill come on one more
oh
did we send assists to him nice let's go
wiping them out [ __ ] half the team left
though
i think maybe we should turn back
yeah this is not a good spot
oh they're helping me
thank you so strong hey oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
no i'm not dying from you you're too
weak
you're too weak come on critical one
more one more
yes
let's go you guys did nothing
this what do you mean swedish tank sucks
this is [ __ ] amazing all right this
way now fellas
three left
oh he's helping me again excellent thank
you
i feel like he's using him as a shield
or he's helping me and i can't tell
we're top frag we're getting it
[ __ ] he knew i gotta take cover behind
here otherwise i'm toast
[ __ ] save me
save me save the swede please
i ain't moving until he does some damage
oh god my teammate's almost dead too
bro we're dead
bros this is so sad
he thought we were oh god i'm actually
scared of being here
come on let's go one shot he's one shot
he's one shot
i don't know if i even hit him but he's
dead let's go
there's one left there's no way i'm
dying no way
nice playing with you two rare sneakers
where is he where's that bloody giza
time to get the strong
all right i'm sorry
but it must be done it was a hug that's
not tanks hug
maybe we should get their base right
hey gg
that was awesome huge
massive swedish tank maybe not so bad
[Music]
we're playing world of tanks it's free
come join
we can play together
and um let's do swedish tank again
i'm ready same platoon why not then
we're good
you got another chance
let's go
very nice
[Music]
i'll switch button after this one
you want an axolotl sticker that's a
good idea
[Music]
okay wait what what was the rules i
didn't see it
jake's been good i i practiced kendo for
the first time
and my hands are all [ __ ] up
you know when in anime they fight for
too long and their hands are just like
all bloody and like
ah and i'm like that's cringe but i had
that moment
it was awesome i need gloves my
frail hands can't handle holding it
[ __ ] oh god i don't have like dead
skin everywhere
don't need to go into detail all right
let's go with our teammates
okay
how do i switch to all isn't it usually
shift
i think my name is technically hidden
soft lady hands confirmed here we go
free kill
come on come on come on free kill don't
shoot him i said don't shoot him and
they shoot him
what are you doing up there huh hey
hey ah you want this
[ __ ]
oh gosh what are you gonna do you can't
shoot that low
haha come back idiot you fool
you can't shoot that low you dummy come
back come back
come back come back come back
come back yeah i know you want it
come on come on come
on come on
fine i'll come to you
nothing stop streetsvang
you coward fight me like man
all right fine
oh [ __ ] what's happening here okay he
got a kill nice oh
sorry mate sorry snorri but let's go in
mate
come on don't be shy we'll use him as
shield
oh he's getting shot from where
[Applause]
what is this garbage music ah it's
distracting me [ __ ]
i ain't dying from garbage music i'm
spotted
that's fine it's fine take cover we
gotta take cover
i'm getting points because i'm spotting
all their enemies who's shooting me oh
[ __ ] they're behind me i didn't realize
that
okay we're good here we're safe here
[Music]
sheesh
i need backup oh no he's gonna die
no i'm sorry
i'm so weak i'm sorry
[ __ ] all right the other dude is still
there
[Music]
come on come on little one
come on he's distracted
[Music]
come on
this is our chance to mobilize
oh they're [ __ ] crazy
ellie avacar that's awesome
[Music]
oh
come on street sign
come on i need higher ground dude
is there anyone left on the mountain no
maybe ah
there's three left but i don't know
where they are
there they are okay they haven't spotted
us either
it's beautiful
oh crit [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh they don't know they don't know they
don't know i could die i could die but
i'm going
reading no
i got greedy it's all right
it's fine it's fine
honestly i don't care at all
hey yo [ __ ] sweden stupid swedish tank
kill me
i'm soviet gang now
which one okay maybe i'll join another
platoon out thanks for playing guys
but uh switching over oh
oh way to go to me
sorry platoon
yes the t26
you know what i need you know what i
need
next time
[Music]
this is going to take me to the higher
plane of
war of tanks
i meant to say were war and then it
became weird world of tanks
getting a million advice yeah it seems
to be
[ __ ] up my game to be honest
come on
i just want to kill people so much to
ask there we go it's loaded
i'm now we're there one dodge
[Music]
[ __ ] i got gpu all over myself ready
happy father's day
i don't think it's happy i don't think
his father's in sweden
i always feel weird when it happens here
in uk
now i just need saliva
i need water
[Music]
all right fine i'm leaving the platoon
if you're not gonna start it mate
[Music]
firstly eddie yeah okay i'm down i'm
down for that
[Music]
who use a shaker cup when you can dip
your finger right in
that's a fair question
okay i'm joining a swede now fellow
swede so i'll guess i'll switch back to
swedish tank
[Music]
i really wonder why sweden has tanks
like our military is so small
i compare the uk and japan and soviet
like why do we have tanks
i don't get it and why aren't they
wrapped in anime i don't get it
i mean it's cool as hell then how what's
the story there's got to be a story
there
right
[Music]
okay well that loads oh it's just
unloading i'm just going to get some g
fuel and a piss right back
boy missionary
oh [ __ ] we started
oh he's got the weak this is my teammate
bro you're so small
may you can't kill anyone in that what
even is that
mate are you taking the piss
what the [ __ ] is that why did i join
this guy
new sherbet
[Applause]
ah bro bro okay you scout ahead mate you
scout ahead scout ahead
scout ahead shush go scout
it's [ __ ] cold isn't it oh i need
more music
conquer the battle fight
thank you jenny appreciate you
i can't hear
okay oh
oh oh are they gonna peek are they gonna
peek are they gonna pee
[Music]
you don't peek the sweet come on no [ __ ]
i'm dead i'm dead i'm so out in the open
i'm so dead what happened to my
teammates
[Music]
what happened to my teammates why are
they shooting me i'm so i'm
do something [ __ ]
i'm so mad about that [ __ ] this god damn
it
[ __ ] sweden no way i wasn't playing
sweden love sweden
[Music]
i okay listen what happened there was i
tabbed out the game because i wanted to
pick a cool music game failed me
the music failed me in the game but i
also realized
number two i didn't have a sip of gpo
yet
which makes all the difference
wait did i click on this
sorry no swedish tank no game
oh like these
oh i'm getting roped in
oh god i get so many invites okay this
guy has like a
big thing on him maybe he's really good
yeah okay now we play swedish tank
for sweden best country this one
it's not suitable for the platoon what
does that mean i need a tier 4 vehicle
mate not happening
higher the tiers the better players and
i i ain't doing it i'm sorry mate
42 18 let's go this one
here we go sweden
i hadn't had my zip yet
new user flavor it does taste like
mandarin a little bit i just realized
i felt it now
here we go let's get some swedish music
swedish music
swedish war music there we go this is a
classic swedish war song
oh yeah
[Music]
three
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh look at this coward
[Music]
[Applause]
he's crazy
[ __ ] i can't turn that fast that was
good
[Music]
i'm dead swedish music don't work
but it was worth a shot
[ __ ] that's the wrong song
okay and wrong tank really
here we go attempt number two
i wonder if that song will get
copyrighted no one knows that song
viking music okay
one hour techno viking mix
okay
all right
i can kill people to this
this makes me want to transcend to the
higher plane of valhalla
i can feel that
this makes me want to prove myself to
valkyries
with murder
okay this time we're going for the mega
flank we're practically going backwards
that's how hard we're flanking
okay how does this gun shoot yeah it's
got five shots
oh it's one of these okay
not so sure what's so viking about this
music but i like it what is happening
here
is there a guy in there it's our tank in
the water
water tank famous water tank
[ __ ] were we spotted
yeah you're dead now you don't feel good
don't you
come on
i need some backup here
okay we got a friend over here
oh back up thanks guys oh mate oh mate
oh mate don't go there i i thought i
warned them
has no one spotted there there
oh good damage good damage hell yeah
come on don't peek the swede
don't peek the swede
oh [ __ ] are they behind us are we
getting flanked
while i'm flanking impossible
armor not penetrated [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
let's go and kill these guys [ __ ] [ __ ]
bye
oh [ __ ] flanked
get blank [ __ ] oh my god he's got three
health are you serious
well you're not getting killed by the
smurf
get out of here smurf [ __ ] [ __ ] i got
92.
[ __ ] that and if you roll a spy with
three health
god damn it see i gotta be more patient
i like it though
you got a nice we got up for yesterday
it's cool i like the new theme from it
[Music]
so i don't want to try a
question
oh personal dog tag should we join some
randos
i have swedish tank okay you're in
i'm all out of swedish tanks actually
maybe i'll do a level three one not
suitable
japan stink chinese tank
okay let's try this
if you want to play invite to me
join the same game the game is free
check it out
world of tanks every epic and if you use
the link in the description
you get 14 premium days one premium tank
the brick
british excelsior tier 5 with 2
250 000 credits uh
tank rentals for 10 battles with
soviet tier 8 sweden tier 8 german tier
6.
so used to use the code and you get a
ton of free stuff so
you're welcome
yeah i would play norway tank but nor we
have no tank normally so weak
norway has literally no defense i don't
know why sweden let them go
they would be better and strong with us
look at this tiny little dude
that's not a tank that's an rc car
are they already shooting it
you want some
whoa oh
oh
real group party happening here that
means flank
damn that was [ __ ] close did you see
that
[Applause]
[ __ ] i can't penetrate his armor from
here
oh wait there's a tank here
what should do oh god there's two hidden
tanks
ah it's happening i'm getting [ __ ]
retreat
ricochet are you serious
oh god he's getting help
where's my looking demon huh what am i
doing
doesn't count teammate
i bad doing so well in the beginning you
know what happened
i'll that's all i'm gonna say
techno is great background music what
the [ __ ]
rc car live longer shut up
the music isn't working i like it though
nor we do military training on russian
border nor are we not scared of puny
sweden
oh really mr norwegian
then tell me all about secret
plans and then we'll see
hey
okay
now the rc tanker for scouting that's
lame
elaine
[Music]
here we go stop fragging let's go
oh geez
we're going all that blasting i know a
good spot on this map
right here baby
nothing's gonna pass this garden oh
first one spotted two of them
oh another one oh with the beat drop
with the wheat truck
damn it
come on don't be shy
come on
[Applause]
no
let's hope no one is flanking that'd be
bad
they're all hidden dude it's flank time
they asked for it
oh maybe we can get here
play a shot here maybe
careful
didn't it
it's oh [ __ ] they were waiting for flank
us [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] god they're everywhere
dude
sheesh what they flanked me they flanked
it's a tiny little [ __ ] you are not
killing me forget about it
you're dead i hope you understand how
dead you are
your friends can only save you and you
have no friends because you're small
tiny ugly and dead you understand
how dead you are you are not that that
tiny one got me
how is this possible it's so small it's
so small
it is so small
help help me
look at these guys
it's fine
we're just vibing
all right let me join the platoon invite
me and i'll carry me it went better when
i joined with you guys
it's math related science all right
that's good enough for me
this is viking techno music the channel
warm warm i don't [ __ ] know all right
oh no don't invite me from other servers
guys
you only please anyone else should go to
bed
go to bed
just gotta wait for the client to
connect
i like the music good background
[Music]
that music slaps man yeah so yeah if you
download the game
and uh use the swedish machine
in the description you get 14 premium
days
and a premium tank baby maybe i should
use that
this is the music they played on
longboats when they went to ray
correct historically
correct i mean how can they know
anything for sure in history right
[Music]
second while alone hold up
there we go we're back with the swede
let's go
oh
okay
a very nice
looks like we're back in the 2000s
and i'm okay with it
okay where are my [ __ ] teammates
going this time
i'm sticking with him
i like this
this may be a bad idea but i'm going for
it
we're gonna pick this bush
and they're not even gonna know
this is my bush [ __ ]
this is the buy bush can't pass
as my bush [ __ ] i will defend it with
my life
you fools you in brazil's
they don't know i'm bush
they don't know the bush ho ho
bush oh bush
oh oh someone stole
your [ __ ] rooney that's my bush it's
my bush
it's my bush no one can pass
the bush the bush
we're just vibing in the bush
oh ho ho ho ho yes
come oh
bush no you can't you can't
that's my bush it's my bush it's my
butch
it's my bush surprise [ __ ] my bush
my bush my bush my kill my kill my kill
my team again
critical damage come on
[Laughter]
you don't have time to turn around
because you're dead [ __ ]
back to the bush back to the bush [ __ ]
back to the bush actually [ __ ] the bush
[ __ ] the bush i'm with a mountain gang
now
mountain gang uh-huh
[ __ ] yeah it's my mountain [ __ ]
you can't come swedish mountain gang
happening over here
oh [ __ ] free kill
bye bye
bye is the afk what is happening
what the [ __ ] did he disconnect oh my
oh sam
can i see this guy no all right
fine back to the bush
oh he's back what the [ __ ]
[Music]
whoops
oh back to the bush
is bush best bush in the game no one
ever talks about it
because they don't know
let's go what are they doing here
they've been just looking at each other
for so long
dude i'm top fragging what the [ __ ]
bush is right some call it camping i
call it have been in the bushes
there should be a tank coming up because
our our friend over there died
but we stay strong in bush
he's got to keep our eagles swedish he
goes megalize
up
what the [ __ ] is everyone is everyone
just sitting in their own bush
some action happening over there all
right
see anyone scream back to the bush
oh no it's just planes
oh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] other
bombing is
there he is i knew that [ __ ] will try
and sneak up on us
you [ __ ] rooney back to the bush
back to the bush yes i spotted his [ __ ]
never mind he spotted us
that's all right
[ __ ] you're dead [ __ ] you is
dead [ __ ]
say bye bye [ __ ] say bye bye
four kills [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is happening i'm killing it
best game
no bush strat has failed us no abort the
push
abort the bush
[ __ ] i missed this is bad this could be
it gamers
oh wait he's low he's low you're low
you're a [ __ ] dead mate no
no no no come on
[ __ ] he missed two
how much [ __ ]
oh one more let's go
back
dude it's only me and and another guy
left what the [ __ ]
i never gotten this far in the game
[ __ ] where's our teammate he's just
oh he's there okay it's me and him
versus one more tank
this is gonna be clutch guys
[ __ ]
[ __ ] all right we're rolling out
[Applause]
if we fight together strong tank
together strong remember
[Applause]
let's go mate oh this is epic
he's scared you know he's scared
he knows bush gang is coming [ __ ]
oh yeah
he's crying
it's crying to his mama
let's capture the flag and whatever gets
eliminated first
all right we're taking their base is he
just defending it mate we got it
together strong
tank to get a strong
all right let's just spin around
yeah boy
oh capture that base
what are you gonna do now huh
he's probably hiding in the bush crying
we're gonna turn in this all into
butchery
is he not coming oh there he is
[Applause]
[ __ ] he's shooting me out of old people
too
oh good shot good shot i'm 92 he's 150
[ __ ] i'm missing like a [ __ ] [ __ ] i
am one shot i'm one shot
abort i missed
no he missed again
he's 23 help this
is huge yes he's dead
let's go yes
top frag very good
that push thread i will never forget it
that was amazing
the music everything that was perfect
hell yeah hell yeah
oh feels so good five kills [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] yeah end with a swedish tank too
that's huge again
i mean i'm [ __ ] hyped now
another one
[Music]
he didn't see me but here i was
push me
all right i don't see the many bushes
but we'll make it work
okay oh we got uh someone in the game
frederick ffc what up man
we have a bush emoji i didn't even
realize what the [ __ ] where is that from
boost that's gonna be all this fun
i can't even remember it okay
bush shrek
bushcraft nah wish straight thanks
good job wasn't even
[ __ ] there's no bush man
here here's some fine bush
oh great bushes love it
i love these bushes
oh [ __ ]
here we go some i've been spotted
no oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] spotted me in a
bush
oh they're using my bush straight
impossible
[ __ ]
we gotta roll up on the bush
if they push you you gotta push them
harder i remember that kids
we migrated bushes
flank him
[Music]
whoa what the [ __ ] oh stole the kill
let's go no no push back to push
back to push [ __ ]
i see you in the bush and you're looking
ugly in that bush she has an ugly bush
oh my god he's too low
[ __ ] i'm not in a good spot
we're going in
oh gotta help
he's dead i did it i did it all [ __ ]
does this guy know what he's doing
the [ __ ] mad lad
stop
to the beat to the beat
let's go
bush my bush
your basics getting captured push
bush
fine i'll go in
there's only two one of them left
oh [ __ ]
so that's the last one anger lord
he dead he's far off dude
let's go another win for the booster
yes easy this game easy
hell yeah
check out world of tank guys if you use
the link in the description
you get 14 premium days and the premium
tank excelsior
tier 5 baby are very nice
and you can almost be as good as i
almost
dude this tank is [ __ ] keller i love
the swedish tank
another one
i can't lose
me and uh marcel were visiting
uh jack and emily yesterday and they
showed us this movie called
gonjiam have you guys seen it it's a
korean horror
where they pretend they're supposed to
be like streamers or youtubers going to
a haunted place
and live streaming the event and it
starts off
like really dumb and and uh
like kind of b-movie-ish but then it
gets
really [ __ ] creepy it was probably
one of the scariest moves i've seen in a
long time
it was really good
hey we got nine year olds in the chat
[Applause]
all right bush threat which bush will be
ours
here's a fine bush
that last scene though
[ __ ] creepy they have these live
streams set up where they can see their
face and what they're looking at and you
see behind them and the hands just come
up for like a split second
[ __ ] creepy name
i screamed on watching it yeah i can see
it oh sorry guys
it did it did i was like i had the exact
same rig for scared pewdiepie
except you couldn't see what i was
looking at but literally the same with
that
arm and the gopro
good bush here
what's that bushlight
dude get your own bush what are you
doing
you're not even in the bush
oh my god oh my god
i can't believe it
no don't follow me that's oh my [ __ ]
god
at least get in the bush then okay
ah my bush
oh this is a good spot
oh we're getting flanked
[Applause]
not on my watch i should have sticked on
the other bush
all right i think i got spotted [ __ ]
mate
oh i see you i see you
talk
you can't push the busher
[Music]
i think we can start pushing with the
bushing
bye bye
we gotta push them now
thanks oh
[ __ ] i missed you're dead
nice
how many of them are left five
are they behind us what the [ __ ] they
flank this
i roll down as soon as they flank
he's dead he's bloody dead too mate
oh
i can't hit that behind another tank
okay okay
you're dead [ __ ]
so anime love it
love it may you're dead mate
[ __ ] he's shooting me oh god please kill
him
yes clean well done
one left two left uh he got my
treadmills oh
am i gonna shot it oh [ __ ] he's shooting
me
through the bush that's my extract
oh could have been a hit so close
this game is so anime that's the last
one
poor fella oh my treadmill is so weak
uh
oh so slow
just die you will never be bush
you will never be pushed
bush gang
i need to patent that push straight yeah
all right
no oh [ __ ] people are dying from him do
we actually have to go all the way
around
oh my god
[Applause]
he's dead okay nice clean
another one can't be stopped ready to go
pro
hell yeah hell yeah another one
another i like it
i can't believe that game [ __ ] clutch
gave me hand i want to look at that
later
that's some montage
swedish tank too strong
i rub my eyes with contact lenses i
can't see
oh it's about to drop as well
it's about to drop
it's very soon it will drop it will drop
it just transitions [ __ ] with bamboozled
let me know in chat if there's any
nine-year-olds in in the game
oh what we're playing with tier three
tankers
hold up
may do a little macaroni
we're soviet now we're soviet now gamer
hell yeah
how is you guys sunday
having a good time mate
[Music]
okay here we go oh
it's a bush game map i like that
[ __ ] we're the weaker tanks god damn it
all right we can do it
[Music]
oh oh oh oh oh oh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's pick a bush which one
will be mine
[Applause]
oh my [ __ ] god am i already spotted
[ __ ]
oh gosh they just charged in [ __ ] i'm so
dead
[Applause]
oh god
vegan king just died ripped
all right we're in the bushes
where we belong
[Music]
hey welcome they will come
patients in the bush
oh
oh come on come on
oh that wasn't me [ __ ]
bush strat still reigns
[Applause]
oh
oh my [ __ ] gone
[Applause]
he's got a death wish what the [ __ ] is
he doing
another boat what the [ __ ] where do you
all come from
this is not me [ __ ] come on come on
get him get him get it get it get it i
gotta get him
yes i got him [ __ ] you i got bush
i got stream snipe bush they know they
brought you know me
[Applause]
all right got him [ __ ] got him
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[ __ ] gang they
they gang then and then they bang the
phoney
it happened
do i have any more swedish tank people
say japanese tank not good but
i gotta be anime at least once
okay new stride new strat let's try
[Music]
uh i think these tanks are like sniper
tanks oh i don't have any
oh [ __ ] yeah let's go with this little
[ __ ] what is that
soviet okay nice
i thought we had a deal guys
nine-year-olds don't kill each other
too too hard to uphold huh simple honor
[Music]
[Applause]
disappointed
the [ __ ] did you do to our base come on
okay which bush was good last time
this is my bush
oh it's a fine bush oh
damn this thing is slow
oh an awkward it doesn't suit much
either you might have to go a little
closer
find a better bush look at this [ __ ]
thing
it's gotta be a bush
oh that's a fine one
i'm spotted god [ __ ] damn it
i'm so dead yeah ah
damn it i wanted to try that tank out oh
doesn't count
[Music]
don't count me did i not share the
screen
i'm a professional streamer guys don't
worry about it this is all intended
because i
didn't buy
all right you see this
[Music]
don't shame me you can't shame me i did
it perfectly
[Music]
oh
come on start queueing up gamers
100 reaction channel no content only
reaction
i'm sure people do that actually i think
about it
did you knock on the door you need me
okay one second guys
break direct back
so
time
oh my god what is happening
jesus christ oh god look at this [ __ ]
tank dude
look at this dude hell yeah
we gotta yes we gotta find a bush and
then we're done
we win stage one
bush stage two stay in bush
stage three bush
more all right so how did these work
they don't zoom anything how
how does this
i got one damage no
i got spotted not again
retreat to the bushes
they'll never find me here
am i supposed to sn how am i supposed to
snipe with this
what
[Music]
[ __ ] tiny little stream sniping son
of a [ __ ] you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
die yeah
thanks thanks guys
let's find the bushy
whoa what the [ __ ] is this
oh what that's how they were they're
like artillery
all right back to the bush
i never used this tank before
oh you [ __ ] what
what does green mean what does red mean
oh my [ __ ] god
[ __ ] he knows this he knows we're here
let's just stand still bro whoa what
just happened
[ __ ] i'm dead
i'm so dead
uh we killed one i don't know how
all right maybe i won't use that tank
because i don't know how the [ __ ] it
works
actually we killed two technically oh
the playlist stopped and i didn't even
realize
replay
yeah redmi notifications
[Music]
ho ho
oh
oh okay oops
whoopsie whoopsie poopsie
[Music]
you thought the music was in-game the
game actually has epic music but
i'm just vibing today it's bush gang
any nine-year-olds in this game download
the game link in description
you get a bunch of free premium 14
premium days
excelsior tier 5 british thing
i don't know what the [ __ ]
okay nothing like a japanese tank in
like a
european town
i remember this battle what no [ __ ]
way i just got hit
who did this
who scratched my anime rap armor
[ __ ] i missed
yeah you better run oh
oh japanese oh
oh
oh [ __ ]
come on don't be shy
nope
come on
there are literally so many of them on
this road
just waiting for someone to pass
lit early
what the [ __ ] shot me here
that's impossible
that's my strength
nice shot
come on stop up there
[ __ ] that's not good
they're shooting us from the mountain
eight four
it's a beautiful day to die come on
oh [ __ ] our friend is screwed
okay we got a friend with us that's good
this
might be tough
how did that miss oh my [ __ ] god
i'm on the japanese
come on japanese
you [ __ ] cowards
slow tank gang
so slow but no afraid gang
oh [ __ ] where
this is a bad idea any
where the [ __ ] did they go
all right we're about to roll up on this
hill very slow
slow hill gang
broken treadmill slow japanese tank game
yeah i should have brought repair and
heal and [ __ ] up
but not as bad as they [ __ ] up look at
these fools they don't know
he still doesn't know
he still doesn't know you there's no
escape there's no screen
one more shawn is dead bye
let's go
oh there's one behind us what the [ __ ]
you can't flank the flank
never flank the flank [ __ ]
charge we got we got the underground
[ __ ]
come on oh where's he going
where's he going then it's literally
just me and this guy left against
uh five people [ __ ]
tank to get this broke where'd he go
where's he going there he is
you can't you can't you can't beat the
tank
we got downhill
he wants to kill me fool fool that you
are
yes now
we hide in bush initiate bush strand
[ __ ] they're capturing our base [ __ ] but
it's just one of them and he's weak
too weak
oh oh
three left let's go
i don't think i got any of the kills but
come on he's toast he's toast you toast
mate
nice
uh someone spotted me oh [ __ ]
oh there it is why am i not getting any
kills
what the [ __ ] is he taking all of them
fine oh [ __ ]
okay i was good though
it's up to him now kind of want to know
how this goes actually
[Music]
let's do one more gamers invite me and
i'll play with you
last game
[Music]
what do you say
will you join the swede try and fight
against him
that's what i'm talking about
what a comeback not bad oh what a cool
it looks so good i got personal missions
i don't have any activator
looks so good no enemy wrapping needed
all right we're gonna find a sweet oh
we're basically in sweden
look basically
[ __ ] guys i'm sorry hold up there you go
there it is may
any nine roles in this game let me know
oh this is level six tank what the [ __ ]
i'm dead i can't play the good tanks
this feels like a good spot
i feel like this is a good bush
the [ __ ] there's planes i'm too fat for
the bush
oh we won the last game it just showed
up oh
[ __ ] is further away than i thought
ah come on
bush gang
oh hello
hello
come on show yourself
come on don't be shy there you are
hit his ass hit his ass
yes we sleeping
first game
he's behind there that little snake come
out
oh look at well would you look at that
huh
trees falling randomly interesting
they're in the bush i know it i know it
[ __ ] are we losing everything over here
no we're good
oh there he is spotlight
oh clean shy
come on come on you coward
[Music]
oh another one
bye
bye one more baby
yeah let's go oh
more bush kills they saw me but i'm in
the bush this is impossible
a tragedy for mankind this cannot be
kill
sex no
all right gamers check
out world of tanks it's really fun
thanks for hanging out guys
uh add code
pewdiepie check the link in description
swedish machine but i added a code
pewdiepie and you will get 14 premium
days
one premium tank 250 000
credits 10 battles with soviet tier 8 10
battles with
swedish tier eight ten petas with german
tier six
for new gamers so sign up use the code
pewdiepie it's
you get a lot for free honestly so why
not go for it
thanks for joining guys very happy
until next time have a great sunday the
music made this
i [ __ ] love it it's so cool
still thinking of that five kill clutch
but whatever
hey user slash toast here
have it sit oh excuse me
tastes good
happy birthday happy father's day happy
birthday
there